well the reviews are in red tide gave me
blue balls a pale person wrote the
finale red tide belongs in ahs stories
the violin boy was the best character
this season after six episodes red tide
has come to an end to what i think we
can all agree was a lackluster ending to
a season that was on its way to be in my
top three it wasn't so much bad as it
was unfulfilling there were so many
setups that weren't paid off like lyme
disease and many of the characters who
they built up died generic deaths and
those who were the most evil pretty much
got away with it
alma but look we still have four more
episodes left in the season and we still
aren't a hundred percent sure how red
tide connects with death valley so like
any good ahs fan i cling on to hope only
to be disappointed time and time again
so join me on this disappointment train
as we sink our teeth into this episode
there's still a lot of cool stuff to
unpack and remember to like and
subscribe i'm breaking down every
episode of the season we start in
provincetown harbor and all i can think
of is how far we are from the dick dock
a local fisherman discovers the body of
chief burleson who died at the hands of
alma in episode 3. so harry probably
didn't do the best job at disposing of
the body meanwhile the town council
headed by martha edwards who we saw
introduced the gardiner family to their
home in episode 1 listens to complaints
by the locals among them is officer jan
remy who seems to be the only one who
cares about officer burleson you may
remember the actress who plays officer
remy as butchie may from season seven's
cult the town is pretty dismissive of
remy's claim that burleson was murdered
that's because we'll see the town and
talented ones which holden vaughn calls
gluttons are working together in
exchange for a place to feed in the
winter the town gets the renown of
having famous artists gather in their
village and the last thing the town
needs are front-page newspaper articles
about local murders that would scare off
their much-needed summer tourists
the gays might stop coming and i also
love how they have all these lgbtq flags
in the background which is totally just
for show these guys don't care at all
about lgbtq issues they just want that
sweet sweet summer money but as you see
it's a beautiful day the beaches are
open and people are having a wonderful
time in this way the town isn't unlike
the gluttons they just feed off money
instead of blood now this entire scene
is five minutes long it's pretty big for
an episode which is only about 35
minutes and you could take this scene
out and the story would pretty much be
the same we never see officer remy
investigate the murder nor holden vaughn
make good on his word that he would take
care of her now there was this shot from
the preview footage but it looks as
though it was cut the purpose of this
scene was to get holden to tell the
gluttons to stop being so sloppy with
their kills in reality the town hall
scene could have been cut and replaced
with one line of dialogue from holden
where he tells bel noir and austin that
a new officer is in town and they need
to be careful when holden bell and
austin chat we get some more clarity on
how this winter summer cycle works the
pale ones recede into the woods during
the summer and the gluttons a don't feed
on anyone in town and b don't feed on
anyone after memorial day this allows
the town to enjoy the summer tourist
season without scaring anyone away
holden basically tells austin and bell
that if they don't care of this problem
he and the council will make their lives
a living hell i stop burger king from
opening in this town
i can stop you too at the gardner
residence ursula reads harry's latest
script which he calls a masterpiece he
wants this to be his last screenplay
live off the earnings of his projects
and to stop taking the pill forever i
mean the dude basically lost his wife
last episode and that's also something i
didn't like about this finale no doris i
truly felt the bad guys like the chemist
ursula and alma got away with their bad
deeds with no repercussions while in my
opinion the most ironically fulfilling
ending would have been doris eating alma
the woman who gave her life becomes the
person who becomes her death i'd also
accept alma being stabbed by a violin
bow upon arriving home to retrieve some
insane brains vitamin supplements harry
and alma find that eli the baby has been
kidnapped by belle noire note here that
ursula was in the house when this
happened she probably knew what was
going on and this all feeds into her big
plan while alma and harry go to get eli
ursula makes her way to the graveyard to
confront the pale ones she tells them
that a new pill has been made which may
reverse their disorder it's stronger
with no side effects at bells baby eli
is the centerpiece of a baby charcuterie
board harry explains that they're off
the pills and he just wants eli back so
they can leave but bill and austin have
had enough and just as harry is about to
be attacked the house is overrun by pale
ones killing austin and belle in the
process and there's something about this
that kinda seemed unfulfilling for them
to just go out like this but let me know
what you guys thought about it in the
comments below turns out ursula has been
working with a chemist and was given old
rejected pills that make the pale ones
attack both the talented and those who
have taken the pill so ursula is safe if
you remember at the end of episode 5
ursula and alma go off to visit the
chemist we never see what happened in
this meeting but it was likely here that
they decided to team up and undertake
this plan ursula saves harry in the nick
of time while just a few moments later
alma will kill her father she has to be
the greatest and she is willing to do
anything for it ursula says they'll
frame harry as the strung out hollywood
writer on drugs who went on a killing
spree and to me this doesn't make any
sense because then how will she sell all
his scripts you'd be like hey anyone
interest in charles manson's latest
thriller at the end of the episode
she'll even tell these students at a
screenplay seminar that harry gardner's
work went on to sweep all the awards and
i'm like if he was framed for being a
serial killer would he be winning all
these awards would his projects have
even been made i mean
is there anything hollywood hasn't
[ __ ] up in the end ursula tells the
chemist they'll get her all set up in la
if you remember back in episode 3 ursula
offered a deal in which the chemist
would get a cut of every deal her
clients made who are on the black pill
over the last few videos i've questioned
what the chemist's motivations were and
for it to be still to oh she just wants
money fell flat for me using the black
pill to take down dirty racist cops is a
far more interesting angle but it's
never set up and it's only given brief
screen time the chemist also has this
military background that's never
explored and we know the government and
military will play a larger role in
death valley so it's entirely possible
we may see more of her ahead the three
other things that may link these two
parts are ursula alma and the black pill
but for the most part i think it'll be
the chemist in the black pill which tie
these two parts together oma auditions
to be an orchestral violinist we saw her
have flashbacks of this when she
initially took the pill in episode 2.
her audition piece is by paganini the
same piece she struggled to play before
taking the black pill don't be jealous
because i found inspiration and you
can't play [ __ ] paganini and alma's a
little cocky [ __ ] here telling the
other competitor she'll win because she
is better than him even without having
heard him play but rory that other
competitor sees something that alma does
not yes she might be a child prodigy but
those are a dime a dozen people will
come to see the nine-year-old play but
then become disinterested he equates her
to being the bearded lady in a freak
show a call back to kathy bates's
character in season four he even eats
some peanuts here while talking with her
peanuts being a staple of the circus but
it's alma who gets the last laugh
killing rory and eating his peanuts some
of you may not know but i'm a screenplay
writer myself so this last scene really
hit close to home in la there are tons
of these secrets to unlocking success in
screenwriting seminars a lot of them
done by grifters who've never sold the
screenplay in their life this particular
seminar is called master the art of
storytelling and if you look closely you
can make out one of the first steps is
the siren's call this is poking fun at a
particular screenwriting method called
the heroes journey which i actually have
a video on using macaulay culkin and
home alone which i'll leave a link to in
the description below ursula is
introduced on stage and we finally get
her last name khan unfortunately no
significance to the greater ahs universe
that i thought there would be she's
upgraded from recruiting screenwriters
at starbucks and has given these poor
souls black pills she remarks on how
reality isn't a red or blue pill a
matrix reference but a black one spit or
swallow the choice is yours and through
voiceover as the untalented masses sweep
across the streets of l.a ursula amuses
that greatness is only achieved from
people who are messed up enough to
endure the pain of failure or for those
who have watched this final episode we
see the chemist in the car with eli and
she refers to herself as his mom they're
off to quote a new place to start a new
life together where she says she'll come
up with a new drug a perhaps one that
will let them live forever this makes me
think of the afflicted from season
five's hotel they feed off human blood
and also live forever so at the moment
the chemist and eli seem to be the
strongest thread to link red tide with
death valley but no real hint of aliens
in this episode or season for that
matter of course i'll continue to watch
and do breakdowns but i'm really curious
what you guys think so drop me a comment
below thanks for watching everyone be
sure to like and subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at think story yt until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much